it took four years for the murder to
actually become effective it was
announced June 8 1966 the best decision
arguably the NFL has ever made so we're
doing a draft today the best decisions
the NFL has ever made without that one
this is the literal AFL memorial draft
we usually use that term when you know
it really doesn't apply because the
memorial isn't really in memoriam of
anyone but this is in memoriam of the
AFL so Chris you've got a trivia
question for me lay it on me here we go
you're ready there is a notable former
former player who shares your birthday
the Dolphins drafted him but he went on
to make five straight Pro Bowls with a
different team hint
you still say his name often today a lot
I mean yeah you probably said it about
30 40 times last week over the last
month that's probably even out 50 times
ah
the Dolphins drafted him he went on to
make five straight Pro Bowls with a
different team he's probably got some
name that is like just actually is
common in I don't know I'm stumped on
this one I'm drawing a complete blank
Troy then about Oh interesting okay yeah
I think he turns I think he turns 50
today not 49 it is his birthday there's
a 49 or 50 I thought he was five years
younger than me I need to check that
because I he and he and I have he's 49
okay so he's six years younger than me I
think he changed his I think he changes
his birthday cuz I thought he was five
years behind me maybe he's trying to
stave off 58 Troy it's coming for you
buddy if that's what you're up to
it's coming for you or maybe it's
already here alright you get the first
pick Chris best decisions the NFL has
ever made well I mean I almost feel like
this is not fair it even like I won't
think we should almost exclude this but
I mean of course I gotta take the Super
Bowl the Super Bowl is the best decision
the NFL ever made there's no doubt about
that the spectacle that that's become
around the world I mean it's it's a show
that's second to none I mean the TV
ratings
it's the number-one rated or top-rated
TV show every year if you look at the
top 100 rated TV shows in the history of
TV you know every Super Bowls in the top
hundred you know so be between that the
spectacle of the halftime show the
pregame show everything about it it's
become unlike any sporting event I've
ever seen been around I don't think
there's anything that can compete with
it right now
it truly captivates all of America on
that first Sunday in February and we
have parties and do whatever else and
block out six to seven hours of our life
to watch a football game so the Super
Bowl to me is of course the greatest
thing the NFL ever did by the way
according to Wikipedia which as we know
is the best thing ever because anyone in
the world can write anything they want
on any subject so you know you're
getting the best possible information
according to Wikipedia Torrey Vincent is
50 so we're gonna we're gonna need an
investigation into whether I love 29 or
50 I am NOT I I mean I'll just text him
and ask him hey happy birthday
III am gonna go with this I am gonna go
with the decision from ten years ago by
the National Football League to get rid
of sudden-death overtime I I hated it I
I still don't like what's in its place I
think that the team that it kicks off to
start overtime should always have a
chance to match whatever the score is
touchdown or field goal but getting rid
of that ability especially in this day
and age where the 50-yard field goal is
not the heroic achievement that it used
to be and every team's got a guy who can
hit from 55 almost reliably getting rid
of that that ability to receive the
kickoff get a couple of first downs I
mean we saw it play out in the 2009 NFC
Championship game between the Saints and
the Vikings in overtime how easy it is
to just dink and dunk your way into
position to get that field goal walk off
and you gain
birth in the Super Bowl so I still think
they need to go the rest of the way I
don't like the fact that and we've seen
it happen we saw it in a Super Bowl we
saw it in an AFC championship game in
recent years Super Bowl 51 and the 2018
AFC a AFC championship game win the toss
go down the field score the touchdown
and the other team's offense is just
standing there never getting an
opportunity so I'm praising the NFL for
making the decision to get rid of
sudden-death overtime but I'm still
revisiting and encouraging the NFL to
take it the rest of the way Chris yep I
know you love that rule I know you want
that I got it I guess I don't know if
I'm all in it with you there okay I do
like the adjustment of what they did as
far as getting rid of the sudden-death
overtime and all of that I understand
that and it certainly has added two more
exciting football I'm not so sure I feel
the same way that you do about oh one
team gets a touchdown the other team
deserves I mean hey the other teams got
you know good players on defense to have
being paid a lot of money all right here
we go I think I'm going to have to go
with free agency is the best decision in
NFL history you know when I look at that
I think that's where the league just
went to another level or exploded to
another level there when when Reggie
White began his free agency tour like
that was the first guy the first notable
big-time name we were like what Reggie
White's going around and gonna visit
teams I mean to me that that increased
the sports popularity one it gives every
team more of a fighting chance every
year to rebuild their football team and
be competitive and be relevant that
season which gives fan bases hope and of
course drives up money and everything
else that way and hey there's just the
excitement of changing players and what
it can bring to your team no wow you
know I'm I'm a Browns fan we traded for
Odell Beckham jr. whoa I'm excited for
this year or whatever it may be I just
think it's it's expanded the what do I
want to say the business side of the
sport and of course made it more fun for
fans in general because you have a
chance to accumulate a few superstars
every
offseason and make your team a whole lot
better and that's what we all want we
all want that chance of a team to have a
chance to win coming in that upcoming
season there's still though is a
disconnect between having the ability to
go out and sign free agents and actually
parlaying that into a successful Super
Bowl type team I mean how many teams
have gone out and just spent spent spent
in free agency other than like the 49ers
in 1994 how many teams have gone out and
bought a championship team and you
mentioned Reggie White right Reggie
White was available because he wasn't
eligible to be franchise tag because he
was one of the players who was on the
lawsuit that resulted in free agency so
one of the benefits to the individuals
who put their names on the lawsuit was
you can never be franchise tag the
franchise tag really does take a lot of
the steam out of what it can be but I
will agree with you on this point free
agency and everything that goes along
with it the salary cap the unintended
consequences of players getting cut for
cap reasons it has created a 12 month a
year news right just doesn't disappear
in the offseason only to reappear for
the draft and then disappear again when
training until training camp comes
around so it has and I guess that should
have been my first pick because my
business in many respects thrives on the
fact that that free agency and
everything that goes along with it has
made something the NFL's something that
you have to follow all year long not
just in football season all right I'm
gonna go with taking the draft on the
road and I'm gonna combine that with
putting putting the draft in primetime
and taking it on the road because it was
about the same time because it's part of
this whole thing selling hope and
pumping up this this thing in the
offseason that every fan of every team
can point to and say this is the thing
that makes me feel good about my team's
chances this year this is that bright
new shiny object that we're adding to
the team this is the guy can get excited
about and and for them to realize and it
all started because they couldn't get
Radio City Music Hall on one given year
so they said screw it we'll take it on
the road and it's grown into this thing
where the draft is bigger
it's ever been it's the ultimate reality
show about nothing they don't have to as
we learned this year you don't have to
take it anywhere but taking it on the
road has made it so big all right we
needed it what we need to take a break
we've talked too much about the best
decisions the NFL has ever made which
apparently was not a good decision by us
will finish the draft right after this
on pft live all right we got to get
right to it with the 3rd round of our
draft the best decisions the NFL has
ever made but before we get there I have
official resolution of the conundrum we
were dealing with Chris the actual age
of Troy Vincent the NFL's executive VP
of football operations who was a
first-round pick of the Dolphins and
later a five-time Pro Bowler with the
Eagles he is 50 today not 49 so pro
football reference wrong Wikipedia right
for the first time ever wikipedia wins
the staredown with pro football
reference so happy birthday Torrey
Vincent who turns 50 today Chris what's
your third-round pick in the draft of
the best decisions the NFL has ever made
well I gotta go with primetime football
I think that's where I'm gonna go next I
mean Sunday Night Football Monday Night
Football Thursday Night Football I mean
the the fact that we have you know
especially where it started off with
Monday Night Football and now is
transitioned to Sunday Night Football
being the the biggest night of primetime
football watching hey it brought it in
you know a demographic I think of fans
that we wouldn't have and then of course
it's just one game for all of us to sit
there and watch and take notice of it's
the only show on it's big time and I
think that's just brought the NFL to
different levels as far as notoriety in
our country and of course things we want
to tune in and watch I'm gonna I'm gonna
see your primetime football and I'm
gonna raise it with something that I
think is just as significant as
primetime football and that is
Thanksgiving football which has been
part of the fabric of the National
Football League
good water since it first showed up and
those are the games that what what's the
first thing you look at when the
schedule comes out for me I look at the
Thanksgiving games who's playing on
Thanksgiving the early game the middle
game in the late game that's the day
where you have the captive odd
so they give us great games are they
just gonna give us anything because
we'll watch anything on Thanksgiving and
in recent years they've done a better
job of giving us really interesting
games and they are very interesting this
year as well all right that's our draft
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports